[Music]
in a part of the country
he knew first this was their tribute at
the last
pupils of gordenstein know well the
story of a 13 year old prince
who came to the uk seeking refuge and
found it in their school
in his day he sailed the waters off the
murray coast
on this day it was a place of
remembrance
as pupils laid a wreath in respect
he had such a close bones to the school
so it's it is a very emotional time
because
he's an og he's he's part of the student
but like the old
student body so it is part of like
letting one of ours go
guns were fired at edinburgh castle on
the stroke of three o'clock
and at hillsborough castle in northern
ireland
so too at cardiff castle
and at the tower of london
guns were sounded for an ex-serviceman
at naval bases in portsmouth
[Music]
and at devonport
it was a signal for the minute silence
around the country
as a nation paid its respect
this
[Music]
at blackburn cathedral bell sounded as
people were invited to light a candle
for the duke of edinburgh
it reminds me of malevolent and
everything you know he's calling that so
it brings everything back ten white
doves
were released here hundreds more were
liberated in other cities pigeons too
as a nod to the duke's interest in the
royal pigeon lofts
the funeral meant a lot to sandra and
norman elmer
sandra lost two brothers in the past
year one to covet
restrictions meant she could only attend
one funeral
for this military family there was
symbolism in today's ceremony
and sucker i think it struck a really
good a right note that will
echo for a lot of people and i think
there'll be a lot of people thinking
that's my goodbye
millions of youngsters have benefited
from the celebrated duke of edinburgh
awards scheme
some of them here in everton celebrated
the man
who gave it his name it's quite tough
because if it wasn't for them then
we won't be doing what we're doing now
we won't be going out with the school
we'll be going places that we go
the duke of edinburgh's funeral didn't
have the pageantry
typical of state occasions but it had tv
appeal nonetheless
they tuned in at the hillbury care home
in wrexham a generation
whose lifetime had spanned his
at the duke of edinburgh pub in
winkfield near windsor it was a first
weekend back at the bar
a lifted lockdown and a day to raise a
toast
it's really sad occasion but i think at
the same time there's a bit of an
element of celebrating his life
and what he did for everybody and for
the country and for the queen
and the royal family so i think it's
it's a mixed
emotion really and i think maybe that's
why the sun's shining really
far beyond the walls of windsor castle
it was a day to reflect
and remember the duke of edinburgh for
those who knew him
here at gordenstein and those who didn't
and for a life past but a legacy that
lives on
james matthews sky news gordon